i'm pleased to
introduce uh marav shohed who is an
assistant professor
of anthropology at boston university she
works at the intersection of
cultural medical and linguistic
anthropology
and has been publishing in a rapid clip
in all the top journals in anthropology
including american anthropologists
american ethnologists
the journal of the royal anthropological
institute
and many more prestigious journals she's
been
even writing about eating disorders in
north america
although today it's her work on vietnam
which we'll be
listening to in her presentation
the vietnam work which i'm quite
familiar with
is truly path-breaking she's not only
interested
in care in inter-subjective
relationships as a topic of study
but her work is notable for the care and
sensitivity
she brings into her ethnography she
engages ethnographically with vietnamese
concepts like sacrifice heason
and sentiment or love bin gam but in the
process
her own work appears as a kind of
affect-laden
careful offering and i mean that word
careful
not only in the sense of being
meticulous but as
being an act of care itself that is her
work is
full of care and compassion as well as
rigorous linguistic analysis of person
referencing
everyday greetings and it's not too
often that you see
care and compassion in rigorous
linguistic anthropological analysis so
it's a true
truly remarkable achievement in the
subtle but
beautifully rendered stories and
episodes relayed by mourab's work
we see how the most mundane everyday
acts are imbued with the stuff that
makes people
into people and how everyday vietnamese
engage
in the literal work of coming into being
as
inter-subjectively entangled humans
that beautifully evocative phrase in
vietnamese
to make a person i'll stop here
and please join me in welcoming murad
for today's talk
which will be a discussion of her brand
new book silence and sacrifice
family stories of care and the limits of
love in vietnam
which is just out now from the
university of california press
so please join me in welcoming morale
um gosh thank you all i i think i should
let
eric um actually present about my book
i'm i'm so honored to
to have you all um here and and to share
a bit about my book today i'm gonna try
to screen share right now
great um so i just want to thank all of
you
for being here and eric for inviting me
and giving me this opportunity and chris
for arranging it
um and i'll just launch right in
to talk a bit about silence and
sacrifice family stories of care
and the limits of love in vietnam
and i know that we're all pretty zoomed
out
probably it being april and a year into
the pandemic so i'll try to keep it
not too long but do feel free to
interrupt me at any time um especially
in the first part when i'm just
talking about some of the um concepts
of the book and then i'll move on to um
to give a few excerpts from chapter four
of this book and the book is really
organized
in three parts with the introduction um
setting up the
scene the concepts and then breaking
down the
the three basic principles that i see as
organizing and structuring life
and especially kind of life experience
and ethical subjectivity
of my interlocutors in vietnam and
that's um
sacrifice asymmetrical reciprocity and
then cam that i'll be talking about
and then the second part of the book
emphasizes a lot more the complications
on the ground especially as people in da
nang and wang nam
um who had more tenuous connections to
the state
and had kind of ghosts haunting them at
times from the past
um so so looking at how these principles
play out in practice when we studied
them in situ
um the research obviously was in vietnam
specifically in da nang and wong nam
and i conducted the field work a while
ago in 2002
until 2008 and then it took me quite a
number of years to
process all of the data and make sense
of it
so i spent a total of about 18 months
in the field with 13 consecutive ones um
in 2078
and i studied families and so i did
a lot of household surveys kind of
looking at family composition
and um routines and that kind of thing
and that was about
80 80 households and then among those
are including those
i studied five focal families
who were they're all extended families
they were multi-generational
multi-household
60 of them lived in multi-generational
units
most of them were middle class
and this relied on participant
observation
on interviews on person-centered
interviews except
what i came to see it as because i was
looking at
multiple members within a family instead
of just
individuals i i came to see it as a
family-centered ethnography
which i think enriches the notion from
psychological anthropology
of person-centered where you look at
people not just as tokens of a type
but really as as individuals
in their own rights i also did a number
of recordings i
went to each family about every four to
six weeks
and um in total had 95
94 hours of recordings um which
you know obviously with their permission
and i had thousands of photographs
and notes and all that so i'm not sure
if i'll ever be able to transcribe
everything but i did a lot of it with um
with the assistance of local assistants
and then
also native speakers in the us and
canada
um and so i didn't originally
mean to study silence and sacrifice per
se
um but really what i was interested in
is
what holds families together in the face
of change
and that was because in da nang where
the americans had landed during the war
and were situated all of the families i
studied
had been torn um they had some members
who
had gone north to fight for north
vietnam
and some who had stayed some affiliated
with
the south with the um with the americans
some affiliated with the viet cong some
affiliated
at times with both and so i was
wondering
um you know having come a good 30 years
later
how is it that families are seem so able
to to eat together and celebrate
together and work together
and enjoy each other's company
um and i found that
um there are several key components that
help in this
one of them is heason or sacrifice which
i came to think of as really willingly
silently and smilingly embracing
hardship for the benefit
of asymmetrically positioned others
vietnam is
full of hierarchies a lot of it
organized around kinship
and the gam which um so sacrifice he
said i constantly
read about it and sometimes heard about
it in learning vietnamese
and then gam is something that i always
heard in daily life as families talk
about it and so
i really wanted to understand this these
very basic concepts like
what what do they mean how do they work
um how do they help create this sense of
continuity
um and and i came to think of them
as really working together to also
reinforce
um gender norms and also
age and class and political
divisions and so
in in thinking about this um
i was really also interested in the
anthropology of ethics and morality
and how it is that people enact ethics
um what does it mean to be a virtuous
person in a time of upheaval and change
and
rifts and ruptures and i saw the
beginning of the 21st century as yet
another moment of change as vietnam was
continuing
with the daimai market economy where
nationalized forms of care
were increasingly absent and i ended up
concluding that
despite this ethic that preaches that
people should be beneficent
to each other should respect above and
yield below this is what i call
asymmetrical reciprocity
women especially young and poor ones and
especially in da nang those who had
sided with the losing side
of the american war shoulder a
disproportionate burden
and this is in part because of the
market forces that reinforced the gender
and cultural norms
that settled them with a work of care
with putting on the feasts with
um navigating the new economy
um and so as i said a lot of this has to
do with the gam
and he sends sacrifice um and this is
really
not um gendered in the ways that maybe
we think of in american or european
terms
as sacrifice being the domain of men to
to give their lives up in war and think
cam love and care as the domain of women
everybody participates in it
um in in this logic but not always in
uniform ways
um and in studying this i'm really
drawing
and expanding on certain anthropological
concepts the
our approach to sacrifice has been
largely to think of it
in the dramatic terms as a religious
ritual
um as you know the act of slaughter or
substitution
and relatedly as a patriotic
act and both of these are highly
dramatic a kind of spectacle
with bloodshed and i think what we have
ignored
is the really the everyday acts of
sacrifice
in mundane life um that sometimes i've
even gotten pushed back when presenting
and saying well houston isn't really
sacrificed and
and in fact um in vietnam it's very much
associated with patriotic sacrifice
but also with a family and with a
feminized work
of care it's not traditionally
associated with slaughter there's
other terms for that
and so in looking at the
the mundane i'm i'm looking at sacrifice
in the beginning of the book as really
kind of scaling
these multiple levels of both the
affiliation with the state
and in chapter one i talk about
a um a man from wangnam who i called
then
who had tried to evade
conscription into the french army in the
1950s was captured was tortured
and then in 1954 when vietnam was split
he was released in a prisoner exchange
he went up north and
um then spent a good chunk of his life
away from his natal family and
and and then also away from his wife who
he married in the north
because he went back with a call of duty
to liberate the south
um and he talks a lot about sacrifice
and he talks about you know kind of the
propaganda
of vietnam is one um nothing is more
precious than liberty and and so forth
but what he also talks about is
suffering and one of the things i
learned from him and for many others
is the ways that suffering is really
supposed to be silent you don't call
attention
to yourself um when taking it
on for somebody else and the ways that
men as well as women oftentimes
attribute sacrifice
to women especially to mothers this is
kind of the
the paragon of virtue is is the
sacrificing mother
um who tends to her children to her
husband to the nation to the community
um and and so this
this kind of guided my understanding
also
of the second principle which is
asymmetrical
reciprocity and then thirdly concave
and the ways that these work together
to organize people's experiences of time
and of their relationships with um
with the two calendars for example in
vietnam with the ancestors
with each other with a state and then in
chapter three i show among other things
how state discourses
and attempts to legislate equality are
really an effect
engendering difference and the ways that
silence
figures in all of these
in naturalizing gender and other
hierarchies
and these are premised of course on this
presumption of the unequal
but benevolent and bidirectional care
and so
oftentimes when we think of vietnam's
legacy
as confucian and as buddhist thinking
about filial piety and some people have
written about it
in terms of a kind of exploitation from
above the power from above demanding
respect in fact i think that it's it's
more useful to think of hierarchy
as bi-directional in the ideal case but
of course as as i noted earlier this
also doesn't always play out in practice
there are those who
suffer more and suffer more in silence
and so then the second half of the book
is troubling some of these principles of
ethics and morality
of sacrifice and asymmetrical
reciprocity
um when when i studied them in practice
looking at families um i think as we
need to
if we want to understand kinship and
relations within a community
we really need to to look at the
multiple people
with their different and cross-cutting
and dynamic and
and really um intersectional
perspectives
and grievances and so i want to turn now
to chapter 4 to give a sense of this
with some experts from that chapter and
just before i do that i want to
introduce three other concepts that
will help us make sense of these that i
borrow
from literary studies and that really
those are the concepts of foreshadowing
back shadowing
and side shadowing narratives
that i use in in making sense of
people's
experiences and narrations and
interactions
so i'm sure we're all familiar with
foreshadowing
um it's um it's where we see past events
as foretelling future ones so for
example if we start something with
it was a dark and stormy night we know
that this cliche
is going to lead to some um issues and
problems as is the case in any narrative
and this is often associated with um
narratives of progress and modernity so
in the us
the kind of ideology of manifest destiny
of americans to move west and conquer
and displace native american peoples
and in vietnam too when we think of it
as having um the civilization begin in
the
red river delta and moving southward and
uh
displacing other ethnic minorities and
uh
forming its own heroic civilization and
shadowing uses the same sort of logic
but in reverse in that
we know already what happened and then
we judge the past
in terms of that knowledge of the
present the future right
um and so both the foreshadowing and
back shadowing tend to have these
linear um narratives
with a clear beginning middle and end um
that kind of direct events with a
a constant moral stance and this is
something that we do all the time
in life and we oftentimes associate
narrative with these kinds of stories
that come
ready made but of course in
life itself when we don't know
what will happen next and when we often
ruminate
on what might have been what steps we
might have taken
there's also the practice of side
shadowing and that is really
to think about contingency
and um and contradiction
which we constantly encounter in life
when we feel
ambivalence when when things are not so
linear when things are not so certain
when when there is doubt um and
increments or ability and so i use these
frameworks to
make sense of how people live
the everyday and their ritual lives and
how they make sense
of um of their life and um
in 21st century danang when i was there
one of the
two of the things that really concerned
people um were of course health and
wealth
and um those are things that are
sometimes precarious
to um to to have especially in a
marketizing
economy um although really in any
economy
and and what i saw is that even though
people
were not exactly eager to talk about the
past most of the time there was really
a kind of ideology of let's move beyond
and let's not think about the painful
past
at the same time there was a kind of um
long shadow um cast by war
um when people's loyalties had been
split
and um also concurrently
the uncertainty about the future during
that present transition
to market socialism under domain and so
um one of the things i want to argue is
that there is really no such thing
as privatization which deu mai is is
oftentimes
in neoliberalism is um is associated
with
um by looking and
using the the tools of linguistic
anthropology
to to highlight the micro instances
of care um and here i focus
on the moral rather than the political
ecology
of market socialist vietnam and
illustrate some of the ambivalences
and complexities of care and
and here i begin with two premises one
is that in focusing
on individuals who care i assume not
the rightfully maligned um
autonomous bounded self-interested
persons
that theorists usually attribute to
western or even neoliberal
subjects but instead um i'm thinking
of persons as relational as evaluative
subjects
whose ethics they come into relief when
we attend to the living narratives
of everyday interaction and here again
what i mean by narrative
is not a contained text but rather how
people
talk with one another and interact one
another
to um to make sense and to lay moral
claims against one another
as these unfold in time and in
interaction
and um what i'll show is that people's
and family caregivers attempts to
provide care
is really fraught with moral peril and
filled with ambivalent silences that
threaten to unravel the relations
in late reform vietnam and so any
harmony
or continuity or kind of sense of the
ordinary that
that we might um think of these are not
ready made
these are effortfully achieved and
they're precariously sustained
and my second assumption is that in
cases of end-of-life
care we need competence people need
caregivers they they're constantly
striving in an effort to keep the dying
alive and comfortable
and yet this competence or incompetence
is at once
imminent it's impending since we can
become
incompetent or competent at any time um
but it's also imminent it's inherent in
any social interaction and that's why
it's also
fluid um and throughout fieldwork
what what i sought to understand
is um how it is that that people
um what it means is to be
a competent ethical person
in danang and i've already published on
this and it also figures in chapter two
the ways that children learn
politeness routines to acknowledge their
elders
and that this is actually an incipient
form of subjectivation
into the morality into the disposition
of sacrifice that has
a lot to do with um ancestral worship
later in life and and ways of taking on
suffering
in silence um disciplining the body
withholding from us
from from yourself um and these acts are
never private
they're never unitary they involve a
range of asymmetrical
forms of reciprocity and they reinforce
hierarchies
and so here i focus on one such
instance and the stories that
surrounding
that surround it um in not
in a case of child care but really in
the case of
older care where unlike in america where
oftentimes we think of the end of life
as highly biomedicalized and this of
course exists people do go to the
hospital the person i talk about did
go to the hospital but ultimately a lot
of the care
is done at home by kin
who have to um also continue
their daily lives their worship
activities their income
earning activities and all that and so
i focus here on a 75 year old woman who
i call babae
and she started complaining to me
quietly back in april
of headaches and then she suffered a
minor stroke in july and then spent
weeks in the hospital and finally
returned home and
went right back to the squatting of food
preparation and
and cleaning and taking care of her
granddaughters
and she suffered another stroke and
this time she went into a permanent
vegetative state
and the family was essentially waiting
for her
to die um and
but they didn't know when she might die
and they shrouded this calamity
in silence so baz husband um
he coped by sleeping a lot and
um saying very little and the family's
women
were the ones who really stepped in to
fill the vacuum
and manage the loss with material acts
of
caregiving caregiving and so again she
spent several months in the hospital
hooked up to machines and then in the
end in the face of mounting costs she
returned home
in december and so she lay in the bed
placed in the living room
tended by her daughters and
daughters-in-law
and what i want to focus here right now
is on just
a minute of interaction and i'll just
show maybe half a minute of it
um that of a footage that i filmed in
january about a month after she had come
back home
and you know one of my methodologies was
filming regularly in
the family homes and i admit i was
reluctant
to to film a um sick
and dying woman but here she was in the
living room
the corner is where the tv used to be
and the family was like well why aren't
you filming this why aren't you taking
pictures so i did
and um so what what we
see here uh or we're going to see
is a little drama unfold that
illustrates how the kin display
care for the dying and apprentice
ethical personhood
and this emergent socialization routine
begins with bear lying
in bed in the living room her knees
locked up right
her daughter-in-law lan pleads with a
comatose elder to straighten these out
um who has come to watch uses the
non-deferential
second personal pronoun me which only
status seniors
use towards status juniors to establish
hierarchy
as he calls out to lan until she looks
up to him
and only to tell her straighten out his
wife's legs um so
i'll play this while talking and and
then i'll play it
again so with a smile and
answers in a plain voice she keeps
grimacing she then adds this morning i
was able to stretch her a bit but she's
really struggling
doesn't matter um reassures but plan
continues with her complaint
actually she's mad at me i'm hurting her
terribly
approaching the bed um dao
it hurts and then he gazes at his wife
as lan
continues to walk on baz legs bending
over to clearly address
that this is what we see now i'm states
in an authoritative paternalistic voice
doesn't hurt
bending even closer he exhorts that in a
scolding voice endure the pain stretch
out the legs why stay
cramped up his eyes then focusing on
that
he adds in a gentler quieter voice
raising and lowering his chin
in a kind of entreaty stretch out
stretch out
throughout lan continues to gently press
on her mother-in-law's legs
working to make backhoe operate with
arms directive
she overlaps with him protesting quietly
i try doing that
while arm's sister-in-law adds her own
command stretch out the legs that her
legs
lie on the bed and i can um
just do this again
can you all hear me okay my computer is
kind of
funny
foreign
okay so adopting goffman's model of
participant roles we see how the two
generations organize the interaction in
gendered and age-graded ways
it's the daughter-in-law lan who
physically takes care of the ill woman
there
while the seniors direct her to keep
doing what she has in fact been
attempting to do
lann in turn has little recourse than to
smile
comply and only weekly for tests that
she has been doing as told
we learn even more about responsibility
morality
and power if we consider the ecology of
this
this includes participants eye gaze
movements and bodily use of space which
reveal who is interpolated as a ratified
participant
and how from this perspective the
exchange looks less harsh
it exemplifies acts of care despite
bad's grave condition
her incompetent caregivers treat her as
a ratified participant
she's someone to whom they attribute a
will emotions
and agency schools land pleads and
imagines or experiences being scolded
and in contrast with those who are not
there daily to attend bear
they at times address her directly not
just
as a mostly but not yet dead body
in shutter's sense they enact a wee
relationship with that
they treat her not as a soon-to-be
predecessor someone who shares neither
the same temporal nor spatial frame with
them
but as a consociate someone with whom
they could still grow older together and
this often happens that people treat
each other as consociates
when their ancestors and directly
addressing them praying to them and
feeding them
they know that bear cannot respond
either verbally or with her body
yet almond land read her knotted brow in
stiff limbs
as expressions of pain and stubborn
reprove
they treat her in other words as still
endowed with a rich cognitive life
even though she is motionless
essentially unresponsive
and on the verge of death they care
in this incipient narrative arms
exhortations to stretch out
models for lan how to act in a difficult
and morally fraught instance
where the daughter-in-law is afraid to
hurt and earn the wrath
of her mother-in-law in addressing bear
um indirectly exhorts lan to keep on
tending to the old woman
not to allow bad's limbs to stiffen and
suffer
even more this is an interpersonal form
of care
that does not explicitly implicate the
market
but though privately done at home in
passing it is a public
act that demands recognition and
repetition
and the atlantan arm were not
professional end-of-life caregivers
they struggled to make their comfortable
and to manage their own discomfort
most days they did so in muted ways
land smiling and i'm sleeping in the
face of bear's calamity
in the absence of prescribed rituals
which are in place for tending and
honoring the dead
they worked instead at treating with
respect and care
this matriarch who for so long had
herself managed the smooth running of
the household
they implicated they interpolated not
just each other but also the comatose
there
as capable of moral action as imminently
competent and yet
and yet imminently incompetent beings
who are engaged in an ethical project
for care
of care for and about one another
and this is why the interaction seems so
fraught i think
we see unequally positioned family
members deliberate
through fleeting actions over what the
best good in sheryl mattingly's terms is
for the nearly dead
they seem to act in unison in agreement
that
even though stretching out bear's legs
causes the inert but recalcitrant body
and the person inhabiting it pain
because she's still a living person
and they have to enjoin that to endure
the pain to jail
and to act ethically in this world
and yet this version of care and ethical
personhood was precarious
performed daily in bath's house till her
eventual death
the following spring it enlisted a range
of baz relatives who visited
periodically
and spoke to and about here as they
continued to participate in the
household's rituals
no one projected ban to the future as an
ancestor
and no one mentioned her imminent death
they oriented her
only as a present and suffering and
suffering
somewhat indignantly i could end by
concluding
that these occasions like baz earlier
quiet
endurance of pain where for months she
did not seek
care for her high blood pressure reflect
local understandings
of gendered virtuous care and daily
sacrifice
demanded by an economy of retracting
state care
but the story doesn't end here
um not everyone regarded almond bear as
innocent victims
amen baz niece and for example surprise
me one december day with a story of past
wrongs and transgressions i briefly
recount this story and the imminent
critique that baz current state
led and to project both to show how
protagonists are
not all equally burdened with the
ethical work of enduring suffering for
the sake of another silently
and also to show how fragile love and
care can be
under both marketization and socialism
and under war decades earlier arms
brothers fought on opposing sides of the
american war
and yet the siblings always deemed
seemed tight-knit
they kept past divisions mute they like
to recount how am had done right by his
youngest brother sin
raising him and ensuring his education
since their father died young
in 1948. these were compact coherent
striving narratives
with clear beginnings and morally
predictable endings
but here um but there is another
side-shattering
genre of narratives these stories
highlight ambiguity
ambivalence and contradiction
co-narrated
and non-linear they invite moral
reflection and debate
in anne's meandering story ahm and his
wife appears withholding or suspending
care
during and after the war and narrates
this tale of
wrongs indirectly it's a side-shadowing
story
told non-linearly by weaving back and
forth through time emphasizing moments
of connection
love and hurt amen
had not risked losing their house or for
sheltering their american collaborating
brother sin
nor had they helped his faithful wife ma
visit him in communist re-education camp
like am sister and anne's mother b
had done amanba's passive acts of
omission of care
which remained implicit and unnarrated
also turned into sinful commission when
am sold off lands that jointly belonged
to all his siblings
and he left sends children nothing
the threads of this story are tangled
narrating shifting effective stances
oblique connections and this and
disagreements that are not resolved
and these are all um worked out in in
chapter
four um
in side-shattering fashion anne presents
a series of contested moral stances as
protagonists hold conflicting
commitments to their kin
she grieves for the now deceased
ma who
who died after the couple left vietnam
but when anne was upset at zen for
remarrying her mother b
defended him and scolded anne blood ties
trump friendship
and story continually descends into the
past and navigates a presence
seemingly blindly without full clarity
of hindsight it relies on silences
and absences not saying that ham had not
cared for his brother
but pointing out how his sister had
she tells me siblings love they take
care of each other they don't care about
whatever happens
they don't care about money and yet and
story is filled with instances in which
gifts of money stood for
acts of love and refusal to give was
equated with betrayal
contradiction pervades our stories and
still one point emerges clearly at the
end when
anne's mother b takes over the telling
land prices soared but amina's wife
barely shared profits from the sale of
their
grandparents land and refused her her
even the smallest of loans they didn't
care
here bien ann used back shadowing using
the present hindsight
to morally assessed past deeds to link
baz present state
to recent and past wrongs their story
which gains steam only slowly
suddenly crescendoed to its conclusion
the present suffering was
karmic retribution for a life that could
have been led
otherwise her voice quietly furious
b says i only asked i asked for so
little
they wouldn't give it this was recent
before bubba
got sick um said he didn't have it [ __ ]
we yield to him whatever he wants
mother and daughter abruptly stopped the
account with b's unexpected curse
resentments over care withheld or
inadequately performed
which could lie dormant for decades came
to the surface with bad's present
illness this and imminent reflection
over how to care
and imminent judgment about who is
competent or incompetent at doing so
tensions subtly expressed in instances
such as when bear's legs need to be
straightened
inside caregivers to reflect on who has
cared
and who deserves caring a linguistic
phenomenological lens reveals
how temporal horizons reach into the
past and future
both in ann and b's back shadowing and
side-shadowing stories that frame the
past expectations and promises
unfulfilled
as foregone conclusions or as unexpected
turns
inland and arms incipient and acted
narratives
ethical figures take shape through
complaints exhortations and silences
these stories and silences color present
concerns over
care condensed and bad's figure lying on
their bed
in the living room unconscious and
unrestful
these not only sustain but also threaten
to rupture
shared understandings of who is or was
virtuous and why
forcing and forging an ethics of cool
not of cool judgment but
rife with cascading affects of love and
regret and so and so here i'm talking
about the ways that
ethics isn't really about this rational
withdrawing
and thinking about how to act it's also
filled with with emotion in trying to
and trying to behave morally
and yet still rupture was kept at bay
ann and b continued to visit that
effectively refusing to jeopardize
rituals of care and dominant narratives
of virtue despite some tensions
their stories where scornful language
erupts remain
almost exclusively silenced
i conclude then that by tracing the
unfolding employments and intersections
of
ants and these stories we can witness
how precarious the work of enduring
in the name of love and care is and how
quotidian sacrifices remain for the most
part
silence in speech but demonstrated in
action
competence and incompetence are
simultaneously imminent and
imminent in social life bringing into
relief the moral economy and politics of
care at home
where market constraints form a mostly
silenced but not
invisible template for what actions seem
possible
and desirable here privatization is not
an option
life is social and fraught to the core
in the rest of the book i continue to
show how participants navigate these
sorts of dilemmas and conflicts
sometimes choosing silence other times
gossip
to make claims of one another in an
ethically fraught
relational world again and again
we can discern the cultural patterns
through attention to the minutia of
language and
interaction which color and even
constitute the ways in which families
and communities struggle
to cohere and these reveal yet again
the old feminist insight that public
ethics are to be found
in the after all not so private domain
of families
families always already political home
lives
in the conclusion of the book mourning
and silent sacrifice
i revisit a piece i wrote for american
ethnologist on the death and funeral
preparations in another family
where we see how the bereaved attempt to
contain their grief
here too i argue that repetition like
change doesn't always beget futurity or
natality in hana iran's terms
even in vietnamese where he sin signals
life
and suffering in silence for the sake of
love thank you
um so i'm gonna stop the share to
open it up to discussion
questions thank you morov um so
everyone we have uh well well beyond the
hour
um to uh engage in question and answer
um
you can raise your hand using the hand
raise function
or send a note to the chat and i'll keep
a running list
and then allow morav to answer the
questions as they come
so um oscar did i see your hand go up
go ahead
thanks very much it's a fascinating
story that you told uh and really i like
the narration of all the at least
um you know the stories
about the multiplications the silencing
as well
and um so it reminds me a bit
of how to put this um
there was once
european uh philosopher erasmus
rotterdam one of the things that he
wrote was ethical books
how to behave and if you would read
these etiquette books now
it's about don't spit on the floor don't
believe yourself in the corner
so now these things
might not be necessary in most places
to remind people of and the reason why
he
brought it down he was not the only one
it was like a genre at the time
so on the one hand an emphasis about
doing something or not doing something
there's a reality but this bit different
and your story really reminded me of
that
how what people say might
be completely different from realities
or
masks uh
you start your story
a million times right
but i'm wondering could you
have to reflect on that because i have
the deep suspicion
that you
masks very often a lack of it
um in interpersonal relationships
but there's no reflections about that
yeah um i i think i am i heard the
question it was very um
mummed but but i think if if the
question that that people
are constantly exhorting each other to
um to perform the cam
and um absolutely what i saw with
thinkam is that everybody is in some
ways striving to do it but in fact it's
it's oftentimes weaponized
to to use against people so you don't
say to people oh you didn't sacrifice so
much enough or
i sacrificed so much for you why aren't
you doing this for me
but the way that they use the cam even
though it's supposed to have a positive
connotation
is always well this person isn't living
up to this standard
you you don't show the cam um and that's
a lot of
what i show also in chapter five is the
ways that people gossip about one
another
and how it's oftentimes women gossiping
about each other while kind of letting
men
off the hook um in in expressing how men
are so virtuous for helping or doing
this and that
worshiping um being convivial and
a lot of times criticizing each other
for not doing enough and so really
these these principles you know they're
idealized and it's very easy to use a
structuralist
argument and say well this contains life
but in fact that that's
really ethnographically um dishonest
to say that that these these principles
guide
every single behavior um people are
oftentimes in conflict with one another
and part of it also has to do with this
kind of it's not like it's a straight
hierarchy where
one um dimension encompasses the other
they
they intersect and and they rub up
against each other
and and this is where thin cam works as
a way of disciplining people
um not just as a way of of
acting well or being good and virtuous
um did that did i answer that
thank you morovian thanks oscar for the
question and we have a question from
david lindsay
dude unmute yes thank you for this this
was
um i've never seen anything quite like
that
and it was it was fascinating
and uh it was surprising how it kept
getting deeper and deeper
i was quite impressed i want to go back
to something
in the beginning of your your
presentation
you talked about asymmetrical
reciprocity
which is something i think i know about
but then you said it's respect above
and yield below and i want you to
explain what yield below means
yeah um so so essentially this
this notion of respect above yield to
those below
means that if you have the means
if you're a senior your job isn't just
to to get all the benefits to get the
respect right
it's it's also to give to to yield
to those below you to um to take care of
them
really and that's kind of the um
so so in some ways you know for the
china scholars it's it's a bit like the
guanxi um sorry if i'm mispronouncing
that
but it's really about that that you're
beneficent
and kind of paternalistic to those who
have
less than you to those who are junior to
you and and this is
where um the
we do have reciprocity and the sense
that each side
does things for each other but this is
on a much longer temporal scale and so
if parents and grandparents are taking
care of kids for example
they're yielding to them we see it even
with a greeting routine where the mother
corrects
the little baby's posture
she does it in some ways that physically
she pulls her up and it's a little bit
um harsh but then the
the words and the gestures are also
gentle and this is
how people i think get socialized into
this idea that
you don't give begrudgingly
you give willingly um and when you don't
people criticize you for not really
sacrificing or not really an acting
thinkam
and so when families put in
so much effort for the ancestors
it's ostensibly not to make the
ancestors angry
and it's also to show each other that
they care and that they're
putting up these resources and they're
feeding one another they're feeding
those
who need also in times of want but
there's also the expectation that that
the ancestors give to them
right that they that they don't punish
them and moreover that they give them
fortune
that that you're able to succeed in life
and and so in some ways that that's what
i mean by yielding below that it's not
just
the upwards directed but that's
bi-directional but
not equal thank you very much
it's it's so interesting how these very
vietnamese um effects
are in some ways universal
thank you david and marav there's a
question from
hotai um in in the chat um
would you like to ask your question or
did you want us just to read it from the
chat um
no i can ask i've had
i've had encounters with vietnamese
women throughout actually central
vietnam
i was escorting american teachers
and every single guide talked about
how difficult it was to
deal with their obligations as
daughters-in-law
they were living with the
parents in law and they were expected to
care for the mother's in-law
and sisters-in-law and felt that
it was a real burden both
physically and emotionally
so i'm not i'm just wondering
about the gender of your informants
whether mostly women did you talk a lot
to
the men in their families and
was there a difference in the way they
approach
obligations towards parents or did the
men expect that their wives
would take care of their own parents
and you know in the united states
uh most caregivers are female
maybe two-thirds three-quarters of
caregivers are
including people who have experience
dealing with um things like physical
therapy
you know i've had experience with you
know
visiting nurses so i know
and finally in a lot of my
experiences women are the ones
who make decisions as to money
how much they can spend how much they
can
lend out and so on so i was
wondering again you know when it comes
to this
as asymmetric relationship
you know um do women
bear most of the burden and why
is that something that
that is culturally dictated
or you know specific to the
families that you interviewed
i want to say that yes as a woman
i probably interacted more with women
than men but
i didn't exclusively interact with
women also with men um and what i found
is that
that saying about women being the
neutung
is true oftentimes women also earned
more than their husbands um and
that could create some conflict although
oftentimes
um i found that men kind of took it
anyway and women
do provide a lot of the caregiving
and do a disproportionate burden
of the cooking the cleaning the
attending to kids
um i am a bit reluctant
to make universalist claims i think um
sherry ortner does a very good job
of explaining this culturally um
you know back in the 70s as as female to
male as male
as uh nature is the culture but i think
that
we can also find critiques um of those
but um i found that surprisingly
some of the some of the
women actually embraced um
being a good daughter-in-law um in
chapter five i actually have a case
that's a little bit different where um
the wife uses her earning power
to distance herself from the in-laws and
of course she gets criticized for it
um but she also appreciates the ways
that her husband is extremely filial
and so we end up having the husband's
sisters and the wife praising him for
being so virtuous while they're doing a
lot of the
work of care and conviviality
um so and and then i also had some
families
mayor but it happened sometimes where
the husband actually lived with the
parents-in-law
and so yes women
take on more and i think part of it
is that association with
um being that of sacrifice being
um the virtue of women that from the
very beginning
he's in is connected also with birth
with
giving birth um and so it's a kind of
dual edged
discourse where
the expectation that you be moral that
you
that you give willingly that you take
care that you be
virtuous is obviously also
disciplining and can be experienced as
hurtful and violent
and so in in that sense um i i think
that
you know obviously you have so much
experience and and i wouldn't
discount it at all it's it's very much
the case
that uh women and i would say especially
it's it's the poor women
um who who end up shouldering a lot of
this
burden thank you we have a question from
you whom
um um please go ahead hi again i'm sorry
sorry that my internet is
unstable so i can't turn on my uh camera
um so um thank you for your talk it's
really interesting
and i'm so glad to see another research
on the central region of vietnam
uh so i i'm just curious though because
when we talk about uh guang people
um right so people have vietnamese
people have saying saying
which is the the people from vietnam
likes to talk back
um and i'm just curious if your research
look at that kind of um specific
characteristics of
of the guangdong people and whether
those uh would
affect any of the you know of the of
their conception
of his singing and began and um and if
that changed over time uh or if you see
if you observe uh similar things uh in
in
in other locations if you if you conduct
uh
researching if you if you pay attention
to that in other locations as well
thank you thank you um
yeah i mean the majority of research was
was and um
and you know so i had much less
observations in hanoi
uh some a bit in hawaii and and saigon
ho chi minh city
um do people talk back of course they do
sometimes
right i mean we're all humans um
but i would say that again i
i presented a framework of how to behave
that people strive to or criticize
each other for not living up to it
sometimes
um but for the most part there is that
kind of
effort to to hison and then gam
even as people yeah they talk back
yeah they joke about each other yeah
they tease sometimes they
they hurt um and and so
all of it you know i don't want to
present a picture-perfect kind of
um idea
of this uh stability that people are um
solid into their roles um but rather
it's it's that dynamism
in how they interact with one another um
that makes it interesting and that's why
i find that attention
to language um and particularly the kind
of the microdynamics of interaction
that helps us see the extent to which
they do
or don't violate certain
cultural norms does that make sense or
did i completely misunderstand your
question
um yeah actually i was thinking more
about the um
like the regional uh differences
right yeah i think i think that's a
great question
um and i i feel like
having spent the majority of my time in
central vietnam
i don't i i don't think i am the one
best qualified to talk about the north
i'd say
in the north is actually one of the
places where i heard women more
explicitly complain
about these expectations that they end
up
taking on um the the role
of virtuous wives at the same time
that they have to do everything else um
but again i think we have many people in
the audience that have done much more
research in the north
that can tell us more about that and i
would need to go back and spend
significantly more time
in other regions to to make a claim
about that
thanks marav next question from
uh thank you mira for your fascinating
presentation on the topic i'm very
interested in the
actually my research on vietnamese
revolutionary cinema
focus on the ideas of
womanhood and motherhood which is
somehow
um share or overlap um
in the sense of care satisfied uh
sacrifice uh
which your research your approximating
research
um present i have a two very brief
question
the first one is about the idea of
silence
um you talk about silence in the sense
of social and communicative
presence um and um
this link to the id uh the the point
that the whom
have just presented uh uh posed
it is about uh the local locality
um so for that i would like to ask you
about the good you or did you consider
the historical dimension of the ideas of
silence
because guangnang or central of vietnam
i'm from guam
and then my whole family and then the
neighbor
on the one hand they share openly but on
as many many points
they just keep that for them they just
don't want to
uh to exposure the pain that they don't
know
if it is if it works for for the for a
young like you know
uh generation like me to share that at
which point they gonna open it but at
some point
so i would like to ask about the silence
which is linked to the ideas of
historical dimension and that's
particularly linked to
the local locality that you you you you
you use guangnam and as the place
to to do your research the second
question is
it is about the ideas of thinking and
and i see that you talk
and then your research focus on the
ideas of
material relation and
it is very it is really amazing
especially you show the clips where the
daughter-in-law and the whole family
have that kind of internal interaction i
have another question
a aggression that that that keep
come coming up to me during the time
during when i
was listening to your presentation is
nowadays many
people like vietnam they they immediate
they they
migrate to ho chi minh city hanoi or
even abroad to earn uh you know
for living and that kind of care
material
care on the one hand is still as it as
you uh show but on the other hand they
show
other form of care like they send
limitations or they do facetime chart
every time like for an hour or two
similar like that
and then would you um you know
talk about that if you if your research
actually touched on that
only other form of care rather than the
material
care that you know you presented um
wonderful already
thank you so much thank you um
yeah so with the cam absolutely it's
it's not
i mean of course a lot of it the most
obvious is is the cooking the cleaning
the tending but
it is also like you said the going away
and earning money and sending it back
and um there is so much when
i talk to vietnamese people my
experience has been
from everywhere but i might be wrong is
oftentimes
talking about their mothers and their
parents um
he's in the ways that these
relationships
um of care continue and span
distances and and spend generations
and the same with silence i mean of
course there's the sonic silence of
staying quiet
but there is also that silence
surrounding
painful events um and
one of the things that struck me
is for example when somebody died
once they were buried you're supposed to
to hold
your feelings in and and not talk about
it
and i think a similar attitude about
kind of that painful past
the historical suffering of war
was not something that people generally
opened up about um i
i have come to wonder um
when these these things um happen like
at what
point generationally and i guess i think
of it because
um my my my grandmother was a holocaust
survivor and she never
ever spoke about it to us to the family
and my mom you know did not think
of her mom much like a holocaust
survivor except sometimes yes right
um but then you know my generation is
asking about it
and wanting to find out and i wonder
if in vietnam also it's that third
generation
and beyond that are asking the questions
that
are wanting to hear and that maybe
as people get older those who did
survive
um atrocities and hardship that maybe
they become
ready to to speak and
to open up and that one i think it just
requires more time and so maybe when i
was there
it wasn't so much spoken about but that
doesn't mean
that there is going to be silence and
perpetuity
and and so definitely i think that's
that's a great question
um and same same with again i mean it it
continues
in different ways it's just that the
point is is that it's not like
love isn't just about feelings it's also
about doings
and you don't have to be right there to
do
but that you show through actions not
just through words so if you say i love
your love you'll love you well yeah
that's good
but what can you do for me is is the
bigger question
often that makes sense thank you
yeah thanks we have a question from
lonnie jones um lonnie did you want to
ask it yourself or did you want to read
it from the chat
sure i can ask i'm just thinking about
um
the purpose of sacrifice
and care more generally not specifically
in this context i guess but
um and i got hung up when you said the
word burden
and i'm just thinking about um
you said there were some women who did
sort of relish in this work
is that did you see that very often and
do you think that's
like a lesser way of being is your um
i guess your focus is kind of on this
unequal
dynamics that that you see
yeah no that's a great question and and
thank you for calling me on it
because in fact it's it's almost unfair
of me to say burden
right because a lot of women actually
yeah they said
you know yeah my husband could clean
could cook and all that but i want to do
it i wouldn't be a
proper woman if i didn't do it and so i
think that
that that is kind of my imposition of of
looking from the outside and saying oh
that's a burden
right but for for many women they do
also
internalize and cherish that work
not always not all the time right um
but and and that's where um
there is that kind of tension between a
discourse that says well this is my job
and this is what i want to do and i'm
doing it willingly because i love and
because i care
um and then sometimes it rubs up against
but i could
also be doing other things so so i think
it's
it's absolutely right of you to to
question that
yeah i'm just thinking about what is the
alternative thing to do i mean i guess
the unequal
part of it is i guess distressing
but like what else is more important
than to care for
i i mean but that's the thing right that
there is a kind of
sense that in an ideal case it works out
well that um you give some and you get
some
and you're not giving the same and this
is why these acts of care are not
fungible
right it's not that i wash your dishes
and you wash my dishes and we're even
the idea is that there is more of that
temple horizon that we are constantly
in a relationship and some creates a
relationship yeah
um through that inequality really
beautiful
work
thank you for the great question and the
the answer um
our final question will be from tui um
and then what i'll do after we've
answered this question
i'll stop the recording and then we'll
keep it open for
informal chit chat for those who would
like to stay another 15 minutes after
that so go ahead tweet
okay thank you it's a
interesting very interesting book
i can see like my whole family and my
other
family vietnamese family in your book
like the condition how people care
in i have some some questions
the photos in somewhere in the album in
your presentation you talk about
the stat discourses i'm not sure what
what you mean by state discuss it in
gender equality uh of which
if you have time to talk more about that
in
when we have informal chats but another
question
is about behavior and attitudes
of the women like weather lame
because i see in the video and the
pictures
so much of the women and ladies somehow
household women like staying at home
or doing some not professional jobs
so whether education and jobs
and like an economic condition of the
family
change the behavior and attitudes of the
women
other people in terms of care and
sacrifice
because i see it's in
my family and other family that i saw in
vietnam
and my friend or some person when they
have a higher education they
their attitude is different so it's it's
not and another one is about um
western eyes like do you
like do you think you're western and you
see it
i consider you are westernized you look
at this article
at the outsider because when i see all
of that
i explain it in different way in in a
lot of ways
because like
the regional differences i have two
brothers-in-law who are
from the center of vietnam so
and go ahead i'm also talking about the
doctor-in-law take care taking care of
the mother-in-law
because the the the culture of the in
the center
like on the property of the family you
return you give to
the sun so they expect that not the
mother the doctor in law to take care
while other family they they even to
share with others so
usually sometimes the doctor not the
doctor not take care of their
parents when they're sick so
so like so when we look at that
we think about culture and we see it's
very
normal and we think about property maybe
it's just
i give you my property to you and you
have to take care of me
um it's your responsibility something
like that because
we live in that condition but under your
western eyes
not wrong it's not correct we can when
you just
look at how the daughter the women
taking care of their parents
and that's supposed to be like checking
it by
doing by nurses or is
it it's just through your explanation
i'm not sure i got it
but through your explanation is
something not wrong not right
in in western culture or in western
context
early somehow so do you think that's
like your western might affect your your
explanations
that's it i am sure that
my western eyes affect my explanations
um
i don't think i was trying to criticize
the system of relations
quite the opposite i was saying that
this is the way
it works and a lot of times it works
quite well
and i think what what it does help us
understand though
is also why does social reproduction
continue
and a lot of times it continues not
through oppression it continues because
people
participate in a system right we collude
in a system
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
it's
um it is the way that things are
whether we want to come in and criticize
that's a different point but i'm not
sure
that we must um the
what i found is that i think because
this was a generation
pre-the family planning and so
the people who were adult and in a
position to care they oftentimes
had multiple siblings and so
it was care was distributed among
daughters and daughters-in-law it wasn't
just daughters-in-law it wasn't just
daughters it wasn't just
hired help the women i think if you saw
in some of the pictures these are not
necessarily uneducated women
what i am saying is that a lot of times
for the
worship rituals and even you know
needing to
care of the mother-in-law who has fallen
sick
they had to suspend their work they had
to take time off
and come and take care and
and so that's where there is a kind of
burden i also found that men often times
it didn't really matter if they're
drinking with their brothers-in-law
or their drinking with their brothers
they enjoyed it right
um and it was oftentimes sisters
and sisters in law who would do the job
of cleaning up behind them right
and of putting together the system of
relations
but i don't think that it's
that it's necessarily bad it's just
different um and and
um the one i i did um
see one case of a family that was
particularly well
off and in that case the mom
actually she she goes to an instant
worship ritual and i talk about it in
chapter two
um so she does kind of the duty but
nominally and then she has to run off to
work because she
she has like an important position and
here it is
her sisters her hired help um the
sisters-in-law who do the work of
of putting on the event and her husband
comes and and worships um
in her stead so there is always at least
somebody
from the family um but i wouldn't say
it's
just women doing all the work and i
wouldn't say that it's necessarily bad
that women do end up doing a
disproportionate
amount of that kind of work men also are
saddled
with a lot of duties and burdens and and
so forth
um but i'm sure that if i was in
vietnamese i mean if i was
vietnamese i would see so much more i
would hear
so much more i would understand i mean
obviously i'm i'm not a native speaker
and so i'm sure i missed a lot
and i'm sure that if i had grown up in
vietnam
i would be i there was a good chance i'd
be seeing things differently
than than i did
thank you and thank you everyone for
your wonderful questions
and um for joining us for the talk today
um
i'm going to bring it to a close now but
i i'm going to stop the record here but
please join me in thanking mara for a
wonderful talk and discussion